today I'm gonna talk to you about how
the Chinese government engages and
online disinformation campaigns so
recently you've probably heard about
misinformation fake news disinformation
when I use the word disinformation I'm
talking about government actors state
actors actively putting out fake content
as if they were the opinions of ordinary
people and then attempt to persuade the
public and this is based on joint work
with Gary Cam Molly Roberts and if at
any point you have questions for need
clarification please feel free to just
raise your hand and interrupt me okay so
my work is focus in part on censorship
and online propaganda this is the third
in a series of three papers that
examines how the Chinese regime controls
information online so the first to
examine how they remove content and in
this one I'm looking at how the
government adds content online and does
so in a surreptitious way so China
engages in censorship and propaganda in
a multi-faceted way it's a huge
organization that is trying to suppress
and distort and control what information
everyone can see but when we analyze
these efforts at scale they actually
reveal something to us
about the intentions and goals of this
regime so this is where him as data
becomes more more digitized we can learn
things about these opaque countries and
governments that we were not able to
previously so you may be familiar with
some of the ways China controls
information they control traditional
media newspapers television and radio
they also there's the Great Firewall so
if you're in China you can't access
sites like Twitter or Facebook or New
York Times without a VPN there's also
automated keyword based filler filtering
so if you're on a social media site
inside China you're trying to post
something on social media maybe it
contains some keywords and you can't
post that this is the homonyms that
Michael is mentioning some people use
alternative terms that refer to
phenomenon
keyword filtered there's also search
filtering so the dominant search engine
in China is Baidu
if you search by do you will not get
certain results that you would on other
search engines and then there's also
human post level censorship so often
times the government can only do keyword
based filtering search filtering if they
know what they don't want the public to
to read about but oftentimes they're
things that happen that the government
can't predict and they want to remove it
afterwards and this is done by the
internet content providers in China and
is a pretty large effort involving
hundreds of thousands of workers who are
employed by companies like Alibaba and
and WeChat and $0.10 and probably what
this constitutes is the largest
selective suppression of human
expression in history so that sounds
really big but at the same time we have
more recorded data than much more
recorded data than any previous time in
history so it's also a time where
selectively the Selective suppression is
now possible so in addition to all this
removal of content there are also rumors
of the 2 million people who are engaged
in government astroturf II so this is
fabricating social media posts as if
there were the opinions of ordinary
people and the official name there's
official name from the Chinese
government for this and they're called
Internet commentator so totally
innocuous they're supposed to be guiding
public discussions and online discourse
but there's also a more common name that
folks familiar with China Minow which is
57 Party members will Maul down people
are paid supposedly paid 50 cents for
each post that they make and throughout
this talk I'm talking about people who
are directed by the Chinese government
to put out this content not individuals
who are super nationalistic and want to
post things they think the government
wants them to post so to date the
prevailing view of activists journalists
and some scholars about what the Chinese
China's 50 cent party does is that they
argue with critics of the regime so if
anyone goes to criticize the Chinese
government then the 50 cent party will
come out and downvote those posts or
will are
you against those opinions so they're
defending China and recently there was
some discussion on hacker news of the
paper I'm talking about today and a lot
of the comments were actually espousing
this view that there are people whatever
there's negative coverage of China all
these people 50 senators pop up and and
then down vote in a brigade or argue
against these negative views of China um
and so we have some quotes from both the
press as well as academics that support
this view and we also collected these
accusations on social media so we looked
at who on social media is accused of
being a 50 cent party member and we
found that most of the time they are
ones arguing with critics of China so if
you argue are you to defend China then
you're often labeled a 50 cent party
member and so in essence the prevailing
of view of what 50 cent party does is
that there are anti disobey
antidisestablishmentarianism active I
pray for those yeah so so that's the
prevailing view of what what these 57
party members do but the evidence is
really scant there's some anecdotes and
some interviews but a lot of times are
actually guessing at this dependent
variable we're guessing based on this
intuition what 50 cent party members are
and what we find is that this is not at
all the case 50 cent party members are
not engaging in any sort of debate or
argumentation they're entirely avoiding
the central controversial issues and
instead putting out tons of positive
move motivational inspirational posts
that seemed aimed at distraction
so what I'll present to you is what we
think is the first systematic evidence
of China's 50 cent party we the first
thing we do is decipher a corpus of
leaked emails there were leaks we don't
really know how but a colleague informed
us that there were these email archives
and when we looked closely we found
these emails sent to and from this
county level internet propaganda office
and in these emails are a lot of emails
coming in of workers claiming credit for
all the posts they've made so you'll see
posts like oh these are the these are
the posts I made you see the screenshots
sometimes they're the the text is in a
word attachment this data is online is
still available on the Internet Archive
right now but even though it's um
coverage it's been largely ignored
because the data is large and
unstructured and messy so a lot of these
reports are coming in as attachments
sometimes it's links sometimes the
screenshots and so we did a lot to
systematize this data both through
automated methods as well as large-scale
hand coding and in in this archive there
are 23 hundred or so emails more than
half of them are these emails of 50 cent
workers reporting on the post they've
made and there are in total over 43,000
50 cent known 50 cent posts so this is
the ground truth data of what the
Chinese government asks it's 50 cent
party members to post and so after we
decipher and analyze these leaked the
posts from the leaked emails we
extrapolate to all of China because the
data just comes from one County in south
central China and then we validate this
extrapolation and validate the
validation I would say fundamentally I'm
a social scientist and we're interested
in trying to understand social
phenomenon and so we can't just stop at
kind of the analysis of the text we want
to make sure that what we're finding is
that there's more validation for it
so in the validation we first do a
survey of the predictive some party
members and then just for fun there's
some sort of validation that we get from
the Chinese government which I'll talk
about so we learn something just from
systematizing these 57 posts in the data
this is a network graph of the emails
sent to and from the internet propaganda
office so the center node is the
internet propaganda office most of the
dots around it are these workers
reporting in
um and so who is posting the in my mind
and I think in others minds as well I
always imagine someone who was maybe a
college grad partially employed making
these $0.50 posts on the side to make a
little bit of extra money but in fact
what we find is that over 99% of the
posts are made by people who work in
government offices at the county level
in every conceivable bureaucracy and
even below down to the village level and
in the neighborhoods and there's no
evidence that these people are paid
anything of course it could be but what
we think is that they're asked to do
this as an extra part of their jobs and
you see some shirking in these emails so
for example I remember one email where
the the worker is saying oh dear leader
these are the posts I made this week but
if you look at the time stamps in the
screenshots they're from like month ago
so it is these are not necessarily
people who you know it's not in their
normal job description to be making
these social media posts they're doing
things like working for the agricultural
Bureau they're working for the court
system they're doing a lot of other
different jobs ok so what we're
interested in is analyzing the content
of these 50 cent posts and so we want to
estimate the distribution of posts
across five categories the first
category yes yeah new comes from I don't
know where and where it I don't know the
time period when I first came but we do
see some interviews with internet
commentators from big five or more years
ago where there's some discussion of
payment so it could be that when it was
first when maybe local governments first
started doing this and they did this on
a paid basis but now maybe that didn't
work for for some reason this is a
cheaper way of rolling out across the
country so it's possible that
was the case in the past but now we
don't find evidence of that yeah yeah
were these posts typically pseudonymous
like if I was actually a government
employee am I saying this is my own name
so I'll talk about that very both both
are happening yeah so we're interested
in the content of these posts and we put
them into five categories the first
category is what we call taunting of
foreign countries so these are posts
that are criticizing the US the West
democratic institutions the second is
what we call argumentative praise or
criticism this is normal argumentation
so these are people defending China's
policies defending China against its
critics the third is what we call non
argumentative praise or suggestions as a
little weird so what we mean by this is
discussions that are at such a high
level that our on issues were ever on
concrete so these are statements like we
should improve welfare for the poor but
without getting into the details where
there is debate the fourth category is
just factual reporting so talking about
different programs or initiatives and
the last is what we call cheerleading so
this is happy motivational inspirational
really content free substantive free
content so an example of a post is I
woke up this morning feeling so thankful
for all that I have I hope everyone else
has a wonderful day so these just happy
messages and as I mentioned the
prevailing view is that 50 cent party
members should be engaged in taunting
our argumentation but what we find is
the following
and so we're estimating so in our
analysis what we're doing is estimating
the proportion of posts that fall into
these categories okay and we do this on
five separate data sets that
successively expand our scope of
analysis from the leaked data and from
one place in China to all of China
so the first analysis is looking at
these 43,000 posts that are leaked and
to know I want to know that these posts
are made across all different types of
social media platforms so not only on
micro blogs like weibo chinese china's
Twitter but also on blogs other forums
etc the second we then focus just on
Weibo which is the China Chinese version
of Twitter in order to extrapolate and
there we look at what accounts are
leaked so what are the account names in
the leak data and then we collect all of
the posts from those accounts and that's
about 170,000 posts so this is all still
in just this one County and in the lead
data and then we actually partition
these accounts for extrapolation so the
thing to note is that when we do
extrapolation we cannot use the content
of the posts because that's what we're
trying to estimate in the first place so
we can't use the content of the leaked
posts in order to predict other posts
across China okay so instead what we use
our characteristics of the accounts and
we're using Bayesian following rule
lists to figure out how do we partition
the data because we notice that accounts
which are making posts fall into two
very distinct categories the first are
what we call ordinary accounts so these
are actually the councils of government
employees they post about their travels
food their normal everyday lives and
intersperse are a few posts they're
making at the post of the government and
we know that because those posts are in
the leaked data but it's extremely
difficult to identify these accounts
because they're actually real people's
accounts but then there are also these
exclusives accounts that seem to be
created just for the purpose of making
these posts and so for extrapolation
we're gonna focus on these exclusive
accounts and it turns out that it's very
easy to identify these exclusive
accounts there are accounts that follow
the local government Weibo and they also
have just virtually no followers so when
you join when you join way boy you're
automatically given some followers and
so these are the ones that never gained
really additional followers and so we're
gonna analyze the the content of the
ordinary and exclusive accounts and make
sure that ordinary accounts are doing
the same thing as
of accounts because we're only
extrapolating based on these exclusive
accounts so then we focusing on
exclusive accounts we first look again
at this one County and then we do it
across all of China so when we do it
across China there are about 2800
counties in China we figure out what's
the government government we will
account for that county collect all of
its followers subset those the ones with
less than ten followers collect their
posts and analyze the content of their
posts so in this plot what we have are
these five categories that were
interested in and then on the y-axis is
the proportion of content that goes into
each of these five categories and this
is the post from the leaked emails and
what we see here is that over 80 percent
of the content is in this cheerleading
category and so this was really
surprising to us because we thought the
content would be in taunting and
argumentation and virtually there's zero
proportion in in these categories and
that's really unlikely to be due to some
sort of binomial sampling error but we
but we push really hard and we use lots
of different methods to try to find
anything that could fall into these
categories and out of the 43,000 or so
posts we found I think 26 that could
conceivably be taunting or argumentation
so the second dataset that we look at is
just that Weibo
but looking at the leaked accounts so
these are posts all we will post from
leaked accounts and again predominantly
the posts are in cheerleading and also a
bit in factual reporting and non
argumentative suggestions then we
separate into ordinary and exclusive
accounts and the important thing there
to note is that the ordinary accounts
and the exclusive accounts are focused
on cheerleading because what we don't
want to see is that the ordinary
accounts are the ones doing taunting our
argumentation because it'd be harder to
detect we don't see that happening we
see that it's still mostly in
cheerleading then we do within County
prediction so here we are this is now
out of the leaf data we're trying to
predict what proportion all we were
trying to predict these 50-cent accounts
and again we see then that their content
is still focused on cheerleading
and finally we do out-of-county
prediction we're predicting fifty Cent
accounts across China and analyzing and
when we analyze the content of those
predicted accounts is still
predominantly focused on cheerleading so
the picture is very very clear these 50
cent party accounts that are posting at
the on behalf of the government are not
engaged in argumentation they're putting
out these very positive inspirational
motivational messages okay we also do a
very back-of-the-envelope estimate of
the size of the 50 cent party and so we
look at the so this is in 2013 we look
at the number of social media posts in
China
how many 50-cent posts were in this one
County extrapolating out up to the
province where this county is and then
estimating that there's something may be
on the order of magnitude of 450 million
50 cent posts so this is a really a drop
in the bucket right but what we find is
a lot of these posts are actually being
made on government sites sites or
government forums where people are
supposed to be able to complain and then
on commercial sites it's one out of
every 178 posts it's not really it's
still very very small proportion of the
posts that are on sites people would
frequent and so you might think does
this have any sort of effect we more
research is needed on what are the
effects of these types of posts but one
thing to note is that they happen in
coordinated bursts they're not happening
at a uniform distribution over time in
particular they're happening before kind
of politically sensitive time periods
when local governments expect protests
that happen so for example there's this
big burst of cheerleading happy content
before teaming festival which is a tomb
sweeping festival in China
this is a time where people visit the
tombs of those who have died and their
ancestors and it's also time in this
particular so this is the jungle and the
leaked data we're in this particular
County they've had protests around this
holiday because people are protesting
over wrongful deaths and so this is a
holiday where people gather
and where people are protesting so you
see this this this burst of positivity
right before that yeah there are types
of posts at these different times like
those to be trust will be to like more
anti-japan so around teaming festival
also the political meetings is when you
see more post talking about offline
collective action so offline protests
which based on my previous research on
censorship is also what the Chinese
government censors so they're not
censoring criticisms of a government
they're censoring discussions when
people talk about mobilization in the
real world so that's what the government
is fear for vlog people on the ground
mobilizing and doing some things
together and so we also see that here we
also see these bursts happening after a
collective action events so number three
Shan Shan riots these were protests in
western China by ethnic minorities that
gained a lot of national attention in
China and after this happened you see a
5 p.m. and email going out from the
internet propaganda office about this
event and three hours later you see
thousands of hundreds of reports coming
back from workers of the thousands of
posts they've made and those posts are
cheerleading and so I think there's a
question an unanswered question that we
haven't looked at which is what exactly
these posts are doing if they're just
trying to change the algorithm on the
social media platforms so that the Shan
Shan riots will not be a trending will
not be trending or if they have some
sort of other effects more research is
needed but they seemed at trying to
shift the public's attention by just
changing the over alternative discussion
yeah no one sees those messages but they
often comment together on other messages
that then get boosted yeah yeah yeah so
we
may these predictions we want to valid
they date them in some way and so how
will we do that we thought okay let's
just ask the people we predicted to 57th
party members are they and so you might
think that's not gonna work at all
because they're not your optimal survey
respondents right their job is to
mislead you about the very thing you
want to ask them about they take orders
from the government and their employers
of the government so potentially their
jobs are a snake but we design a survey
anyway where we take a random sample of
the predicted 50 cent accounts we
administer a double-blind survey on
weibo through direct messaging and we
ask them a survey question that says I
saw your comment it's really inspiring I
want to ask do you have any public
opinion guidance management or online
commenting experience so we're not using
the term 50 cent we're using the kind of
government's own language around
managing public discourse and opinion
okay and the important thing is that we
ask this question of the predicted 50
cent accounts but we validate this
validation by asking the exact same
question of a random sample of the known
50 cent accounts from the leaked data we
ask the same question of a random sample
of accounts unlikely to be 50 cent in
the same localities throughout China
yeah so we're predicting accounts across
China and so the survey is of those
predicted accounts across China but
we're also asking the same question of
the jungle on accounts and we're also
asking the same question of accounts
throughout China that are unlikely to be
think to be 50 cent okay and so what we
find is that on the predicted 50 cent
accounts 59 percent say yes to that
question yes I do have this online
opinion management experience if we look
at the known 50 cent account so this is
just in jungle in the leaked data 57%
say yes they have this experience and
then if we look at the random sample of
accounts that are unlikely to be 50 cent
only 19% say yes and so there's
no statistically significant difference
between the predicted and known but
there is between the predicted and those
are unlikely yeah that's very very crude
we do have a slightly slower response
rate and the predicted and known and
those response rates are similar again
and you have a higher response rate in
the random sample yeah I think it's
explained by the bias that whenever you
read a survey question you think it's
asking about something relevant to you
and so you're likely to interpret
understand that question in your context
so even if you are not a 50 cent party
member you may think about this question
as do I have any influence online or do
I
Maiki opinion leader online and you
could respond yes that question for that
different very different reason okay so
we also just for fun well not for fun
but I had some validation by the Chinese
government we posted a draft of our
paper we sent it to a few colleagues to
get feedback we put the poster sorry we
put the paper on our websites but we
didn't link it to the front page so we
thought unless you had the link you
shouldn't be able to see the paper but I
think two weeks later reporter from
Bloomberg contacted us and said oh I saw
this new paper that you have we're
writing an article about it do you want
it can you answer these questions we're
like what new paper we don't have a new
paper out can you not write your article
but they're like no so eventually this
led to an editorial in the Global Times
which is a very nationalist newspaper
with ties to the Chinese propaganda
department China's propaganda department
and in that editorial is published in
Chinese so it seemed aimed at China's
domestic audience and a myths to the
fact that they do public opinion
guidance
it offers confirmation or it doesn't it
doesn't dispute the veracity of the
leaked archive and acknowledges that the
purpose of this effort is to stop the
spread of grassroots social issues
so we could think of this maybe yes
posting a survey questions the
government do you agree with our results
and the government says yes and and see
you might think why why do they why do
they do this and in the editorial they
say they explain why so they say Chinese
society is generally in agreement
regarding the necessity of public
opinion guidance so we thought this is a
testable hypothesis are people in
agreement so we collected all the
comments that followed this editorial
and we say that there those comments yes
more than eighty percent of those
comments say Chinese government
definitely should have public opinion
guidance and manage discussions online
but we also looked at way broad
discussions potentially a little bit
more representative of the online
population and there only thirty percent
agree but there is the rest of the
discussion was much more about debate is
this a good use of Chinese government
resources to do this or is this kind of
a waste of money that the government is
putting out this all this effort into
this maybe they could be making better
use of their time yes so I give you any
additional ability to validate your
predicted government accounts so given
that Global Times is very nationalistic
it's hard to know if it's government
coordinated or if the readers of Global
Times are just they have extreme views
on this on this issue so that's hard to
disentangle but so so far for me kind of
the theoretical implications of this is
that given my work on censorship and now
I'm propaganda we can actually reduce
China's strategy for managing
information online to to very very
simple rules the first is don't engage
on controversial issues so that means
don't censor criticism so even though we
might think that authoritarian or
totalitarian regimes don't allow
criticism that's not the case in China
they don't censor they don't remove
those criticisms and they don't argue
against those critiques so they want to
leave leave those criticisms to be and
second strategy is to stop collective
action and stop on the ground
mobilization there they are
that's what they're censoring as I
mentioned before and a lot of this
cheerleading also seems aimed at
distracting
prior to periods of time when there's
collective action and then after a
collective action events as a the
broader implications is that it's okay
to have grievances but it's not okay to
mobilize and it's not okay to talk about
globalization because that's what this
online censorship and propaganda is
doing it's reducing people's knowledge
of the fact that others are mobilizing
and others are taking action together in
the real world so likely it might have
an effect on depressing the kind of
cyber skill mobilization know something
recently I made a post wave about June
4th it would never even get on there
really right I mean yeah so that's so
that's keyword censored but what we find
is that so there's some other is that so
few people know about June force at this
point or care that people are not
posting that and instead they're much
less based on other studies of college
students and surveys of of college
students of their knowledge of these
types of political events and political
knowledge it's just very low yeah yes
that's right that's right because of a
curricular reform and it's just yeah so
what when we're talking about censoring
of criticism we're talking about
censoring accusations of corruption of
leaders criticizing policies even
criticisms of kind of China's political
structure and the institutions that we
see as being uncensored another oops did
I somehow okay hmm okay somehow it's cut
off I think another implication is that
is about the effect of distraction
instead of argumentation so the idea is
that if you engage in debate that just
solidifies and intensifies the viewpoint
of those that you're arguing against and
instead a much more effective strategy
is just to change the topic and get
people interested in other things it's
actually better yes I think that's a
that's something that the data this data
does not allow us to examine but is
something that I think would be
interesting to examine in the future
because we collect leave these accounts
and see are they doing downloading
behavior but wave was not designed to do
downloading in that way but potentially
you might want to look at account names
across platforms where there are is
downloading to see if you can see this
phenomenon so I'm going to stop there in
terms of the substance but I look
forward to the discussion your other
questions
[Applause]